hello and welcome to the new world
review a source for everything anime and
manga and today i'm here to present a
very intriguing thought regarding a
certain member of the phantom troupe
being feitan
and in particular his potential
connection to the zoltic family and in
particular
even more in particular the idea that he
may very well be a long lost zeldik
brother which yes if you've not heard
this idea before then i'm sure it sounds
absurd but there is actually a shocking
amount of merit to it there's a ton of
evidence that makes all the sense in the
world however i should also say there's
plenty of counter evidence as well and
furthermore as
is quite standard with hunter hunter
there's also a bunch of misinformation
out there due to some very interesting
changes made in the anime and speaking
of changes if you are not currently a
subscriber to the new world review then
i cannot recommend enough hitting that
delightful red button which will result
in regular hunt on content being
uploaded straight into your youtube feed
and also just before we begin i want to
give a shout out to grace hanley who
sent me an email recently with their
phaeton zodiac theory it was quite fun
to read through and includes a lot of
what we'll be talking about here today
but we are going to begin this strange
train of thought in meteor city during
the chimera ant arc because this really
is the crux of everything without this
one thing i would probably dismiss the
phaeton zoldic idea entirely however
during the phantom troops battle against
zazan and her minions we get to explore
kalato zoldik for the first and well
only time in the series thus far and i
have a whole video on kalito regarding
this specific topic as well which you
should absolutely check out but tldr
this is where kalito reveals his
motivation for joining the phantom troop
which is shown in the following panel
but i won't give up no matter how many
years it takes i want to get my
brother back and in the kalato video i
explore who that brother may be because
essentially it can't be either illumi or
milikey because there's no call to get
them back meanwhile it could be killua
or alaka
one of which had obviously abandoned the
family and the other was isolated by the
family however neither of them tie in
particularly nicely with this core
decision to join the phantom troupe
which if you're keeping count leaves us
with a very unfortunate
zero brothers left unless there is a
secret
sixth brother and at this stage i should
point out that kalato was having this
monologue whilst watching feitan fight
kaloto's focus is geared entirely
towards feitan and in the manga there's
this very interesting page which
juxtaposes a zoldic family photo
directly against a panel of feitan and
this comes right after kalato's
statement about wanting to get his
brother back and so this is where the
phaeton zoldick idea is properly born
the thought being that alaka joined the
phantom troop in an effort to recover
feitan and this is togashi making a
visual link between feitan and the
zoldik family
and here's the thing really if this were
any other series i would not read so
strongly into panel juxtaposition like
this like if this was one piece or
something i would just shrug it off and
go i think we're reading too much into
that but hunter hunter is a very
different beast tagashi is actually
pretty disgustingly laid and supremely
intentional when it comes to portraying
his ideas visually which is why i
strongly believe that he would not
construct a page like this just for the
fun of it with two completely unlinked
images given roughly equal balance
to be fair that is just me though and
this subjective visual analysis is
obviously not enough to draw any
conclusion but this page combined with
kalato's dialogue from the previous page
is the seed and here's another thing i
should say at this stage even prior to
this chapter feitan was long suspected
to have been a zoldic albeit by much
more speculative information
from the moment he appeared in the
series parallels were drawn between his
design and those of the zodik family
members and a very popular one is to
compare feitan's eyes to those milikey
or killua as well as his spiky black
hair and general sizing which are also
quite killer-esque
which is one of those unavoidable
comparisons every time a character
appears with vaguely similar features in
any fandom people go fairly insane with
family tie theories but the most popular
and often cited physicality idea with
feitan
is the idea that he can change his hands
into claws in a very similar manner to
which killer does which was shown when
he killed a miscellaneous mafia member
at the auction during york new city or
more specifically i should say that it
was shown during the orkney city arc in
the 2011 anime adaptation because this
is one of the giant pieces of
misinformation surrounding this idea as
much as i do like the phaeton zodiac
thought he never demonstrates this claw
ability
in both the manga and the 1999 anime
adaptation feitan is not the one to kill
the mafia member it's actually franklin
who finishes him off with some nen
bullets so this whole claw similarity
cannot be used as evidence for phaeton
zoltic although it does bring up the
question of exactly
why the 2011 anime chose to do this for
the most part it's very faithful to the
manga but every now and then there's
this weird change it almost seems to be
intentionally building a separate canon
within the 2011 series and another
famous example of this would be omitting
the character of gyro and in my opinion
intentionally structuring the events of
the chimera antarctic so that it looks
like gyro ultimately became the ant king
marouane
an idea that the manga goes to great
lengths to contradict so this could be
an example of that this could be the
anime producers wanting to build
something of their own or even just give
a nod to the phaeton's arctic idea
alternatively it could have been made
for purely dramatic reasons you know
consider the whole scene in context
we've just seen franklin take out a
whole room of mafia schmucks so it might
be a bit repetitive to watch him do
it again and feitan does have the
ultimate one-liner at the end being
family
what's that so it's a very reasonable
idea to just give him the kill as well
and i should also point out that feitan
is clearly using aura to enhance his
hand to the point where it becomes like
a blade whereas killer seems to perform
this technique almost completely
naturally so there are key differences
in what's happening even if we were to
accept it as evidence which i'm afraid
we can't
now there's also a fair few more ideas
that make feitanzoldic a tricky idea to
work with
most of them coming from the zoldic
family structure itself firstly nen
affinities the zoldic family have a very
well defined pattern whereby whitehead
members are all transmuters which can be
seen in kilowatt silver and dino and the
blackhead members are all manipulators
which encompasses illumi kalato kikyo
and miliki i know we also have alika but
alaka's a weird one because her net
affinity is never specified and nanika
kind of overrides any rules that have
ever existed there is also another
notable exception maha zaldik who is an
enhancer although to be fair we have no
idea what his hair color was or even if
he ever had hair so the pattern does
remain intact from zeno downwards anyway
the point is that as a black-haired
transmuter feitan works completely
counter to this pattern if he was a
fully fledged zoldic sibling then he
should be a natural manipulator or if he
was a zelda transmuter then he should
have white hair
so this is a fairly strong point against
the idea furthermore we do also have the
fun
issue of feitan's age because when
trying to slot him into the zodic
structure another pattern that doesn't
follow is the naming scheme
because every subsequent zeldik
sibling's name begins with the last
character of the prior sibling so for
example we have illumi the me of which
gets taken and put on miluki
the key of which gets taken to become
kilauea from which the a gets taken to
alaka from which the car gets taken to
become koloto
and given how rather smoothly this works
out it doesn't leave a whole lot of
options to slot feitan in and the
obvious one would be to make him the
eldest brother but for that we would
need to assume that feitan is not his
real name as to fit the pattern it would
need to end with the i sound to become
illumi but fun fact here as well feitan
also has a last
name which is porter feitan porter which
would mean that for this to work both of
his names would need to be fake
meanwhile the only other option would be
that feitan slots in between kilwa and
kalato and that alaka or more accurately
nanika
pretty much forced their way into the
family in phaeton's place which is
perfectly reasonable until you think
about how that would make feitan younger
than killua which he certainly is not
and just on that here's another sort of
misconceived fact it's very commonly
stated within the fanbase that feitan is
28 years old this age gets tossed around
very casually but to the best of my
knowledge this is never confirmed
in either the series or the data books
and where this age seems to stem from is
this picture of voice actor tom bower
who plays phatan in the dub of the 2011
hunthunter anime and apparently listed
on his audition material
for the role is feitan's age which
clearly states 28 and quite frankly
i just don't know where this information
comes from if anyone can confirm that
then please please do drop it in a
comment below however right now i really
only have two conclusions the most
favorable
of which is that they were given this
information directly from the japanese
production team
or there's the other one where the
english production team just you know
made it up they took an educated guess
to help the actor build the character
and another thing that could have
happened as well is that the japanese
team took a guess and then passed out
onto the english team either way this is
the only source i can find that states
feitan's age and i really don't think we
can take that as a confirmed fact with
that said let's briefly explore what
would be the case if it was and in many
ways it does work out in the theory's
favor primarily because illumi zoldick
is 24 so bam feiten would automatically
become the older sibling which is the
most natural slot for him i would argue
the only slot but here we do also need
to bring kikio into this equation
because she is 42 and thus she would
have been 14 at the time of giving
birth to feitan which is that's quite
young not impossible
i suppose but very young and this leads
quite nicely into one of my two main
conclusions for the video because with
everything we've examined i really can't
state with any solidity that feitan is
the child of both
kikyo and silvazoldik there are just far
too many inconsistencies in the pattern
for that to be the case however i do
think it is
quite possible that feiten could be the
half-brother of the other's older
siblings so let me explain
firstly we do know for a fact that
feitan is a founding member of the
phantom troop
thus making his home meteor city
unfortunately we have no idea how long
ago this was but we also know thanks to
two separate data books that kikio
originated from meteor city as well
before marrying into the zodiac family
so the situation could be as follows
kikio and her son feiten are residents
of meteor city kikio comes across silva
and he proposes
somehow i'm sure it's all very romantic
but on the condition that her son
remains in meteor city because well
he ain't no zoldic or we could even have
the opposing scenario where feitan was
the first son of silva but born to
another woman and silva is 46 so he
would have been 18 at the time of
feitan's birth which is a bit more of a
reasonable number compared to that of
kikyu however for whatever reason things
go very wrong with this woman and this
baby feitan prompting silva to abandon
both them in meteor city at which point
he may very conveniently meet kikio and
take her home to the mountain realm thus
still making feitan a half-brother but
also giving him zodic blood and either
one of these scenarios does fix the
inconsistencies found elsewhere firstly
feitan can be a blackhead manipulator
because you've introduced another set of
genetics into the family and he can also
keep his name because the naming scheme
only applies to kikio's children
and his last name porter could have been
the maiden name of his mother but it
also puts kalato in a convenient
position to get his brother back because
feitan would be kaloto's half-brother
whom he may have found out about whilst
overhearing kikio and or silva speaking
one day why is kalito so driven to take
back a brother that he doesn't even know
well it's a very different question
as it is i find it hard to believe that
kalato is driven to get any of his
brothers back given that he's the
youngest and doesn't really spend any
time around any of them but once again
that's a very different question but as
for the other potential conclusion i
have well it's a bit more of a meta
answer but one that i also feel is
equally as likely which is that feitan
was originally supposed to be a zoldic
brother but togashi
changed his mind and here we need to
head back to the seed thought which is
kalato's inner monologue during the
chimera ant arc something to really bear
in mind when we look at this page is
that this took place before the
introduction of alaka
so when we're looking at this page
featuring the zordik family photo at the
time
nobody actually knew who this mystery
sibling in the back was and here togashi
could have been strongly hinting that
the mystery zodic in the picture was
feitan
however after the events of the chimera
antarc togashi may have decided that he
needed a device to heal gone as well as
take killer out of the picture
as well as set up the dark continent
creatures in general and so the best
solution for that
would be a new zoldic sibling in alaka
because i do want to emphasize that
as much as togashi is absolutely
brilliant with portraying ideas on a
very micro scale he
is most certainly not a long-term writer
his plans for the future are quite
deliberately vague which gives him the
flexibility to explore whatever he wants
at any given time it's one of the great
charms of hunter hunter you never have
any idea what's going to come next
because
well tagashi didn't when he was writing
it and kalito's revelation of wanting to
get his brother back was published in
2005. meanwhile the chimera antarc would
not finish publication until 2011
because if you know hiatuses and all
that
which i point out because six years is a
mighty mighty long time
more than enough to seriously rework
your original ideas and i think it's
entirely possible that in 2005
togashi wrote the scene intending for
feitan to be azoldic however when 2011
came along tagashi had grown
changed evolved his ideas and decided to
go in a different direction which going
forward is pretty clear to see because
kalato's mission has never been brought
up or even hinted at since
despite the fact that both carlito and
the phantom troupe have been seen quite
a bit during the succession war arc now
this would leave kalato's statement in
2005 as a pretty massive problem for
tagashi to deal with going forward
however this would not be the first plot
hole or inconsistency that hunter hunter
has to offer far from it but in the end
that's the best i can really do to reach
the phaeton's aldik idea what i do know
is that barring any kind of crazy dark
constant menus from alka feitan is
highly unlikely to be the son of both
silva and kikyo there are just too many
conflicting pieces of evidence
however those do become quite irrelevant
if feitan is the son of only one of
kikio or silva thus becoming a
half-brother of our established siblings
but like i said it's also entirely
possible that togashi did intend this to
be true at one stage but then changed
his mind later on hunter hunter is a bit
like that sometimes which is i suppose
one of the many reasons why it makes the
series
infinitely intriguing to discuss but
what do you guys think please do leave
your thoughts in the comments below or
even join my discord server and if
you're gained for more haunted content
then please to go and check out some of
my other videos or even subscribe to
the channel for regular hunt on glory
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review and i'll see you next time